The gestures to work with for 1 environment
One technique works on your ball control,
your information shots and your controls.
Great that,
your game long and I run,
pass
and your strikes.
Two physical conditions,
work your speed,
your strength,
your gesture to be ready to give your best to each hand.
Self-confidence,
concentration,
management,
happiness management.
These are elements created to perform.
Believe in yourself and your abilities.
4 tactics,
understand your role on the field,
Learn to position yourself and move on the field,
communicate and impose your rhythm as a midfielder.
Subscribe and tell me in comments,
what theme you would like to see on 1 next video?